start with a base color for the
surrounding tissue then we use voro
noise to build distinct cells you can
add some detail by sampling noise using
the direction Vector a simple dot
product between the cell Direction and
light gives you some shading and eyes
are easy to make with circle sdfs We'll
add some color and more noise using the
direction vector and a little more
shading by using smooth step from the
center of each cell some nasty looking
veins can be created with a marbling
pattern then light each eyeball add a
little highlight with smooth step for a
super shiny look blinking is really easy
with smooth Step in
Time and voila you have some creepy eyes
using Shader
Magic